I was interested in the there are a lot
of different things at once one was just
a character who's sort of always in the
background the type of character in a
movie who's the best friend or the
girlfriend or the neighbor and that
untold story of that person so that was
interesting to me because so often when
you're writing a screenplay or a play
which is my background the protagonist
is supposed to be after something very
clear and meeting all these obstacles
and I was I was curious about another
experience of life and um how a person
moved into the protagonist role in her
own life so and i figured that having
sex with a young kid was the best way to
do that that was separate yeah i was
thinking more i was interested in that
that older woman younger man
relationship from the woman's point of
view i just hadn't seen that before so i
wrote a draft and then we actually went
to the sundance institute right to the
lab there i saw a lot of thank yous
icing that was yeah we are very grateful
to the sundance institute yeah this went
to the screenwriters lab yeah yeah and
then um got a lot of notes from a lot of
different wonderful screenwriters and
came back and wrote an absolutely
terrible draft of it and then kind of
recovered from that hopefully um and
that it wasn't it was about it was about
two years I think yeah pretty steady
work I remember Blythe you know and you
talked you know times about about
wordings of things and because she's
such an amazing actress and such an
amazing theatre actress
that if something is is hard for her to
get out you know yeah we heard it
definitely if it was I mean I always
listen to them if there was a something
that felt unsayable or or too repetitive
or something I think Jeremy yeah was the
hardest rose you find him he's really
terrific yeah you send yeah Chris
wheeler he came in an audition he's
amazing he's just an amazing actress on
that HBO show girls and at the time when
we cast him they were just they just
finished shooting the first season so I
really hadn't seen it and I couldn't see
really tape on him but he came in and
just really blew me away and that was
our concern with that with that
character is because it's a we didn't
want his character to seem to knowing
and therefore he's taking advantage of a
me or too young and therefore Amy's
taking advantage of him and that was
very tricky with my background in acting
I kind of can i connect with actors and
know what they're what they're up
against and what they're going through
and and a lot of it is you know who I
cast that's a big part of of casting a
film for me it's like if you cast the
right person a lot of my work isn't done
but there's a just so much that I count
on that actor to bring so much to the
role I'm and therefore on this set i
give the i try to give the actors a lot
of space and not really control them too
much I mean will usually start off in a
place and if it's something I'm usually
they surprised me and I'm always happy
with it but that's that's what's helped
me in from my background as an actor in
in working with them I just feel there's
some amazing artists you know actors are
amazing artists and they they they
deserve that space and what I you know
when I look at the film most of the
choices that I've made in the takes that
I chose and we're
you know things were they surprised me
and it's something different and where I
was just letting them go not in not
doing improv but more line readings or
gestures and or emotions you know that
kind of thing